born in 1606
rembrandt became a hugely successful
painter when he was still only in his
20s
he earned a fortune and lived a wildly
extravagant life
but by his early fifties he was all but
bankrupt
he had to sell his house and all the
beautiful objects he had accumulated
in the world of respectable prudent
dutch merchants his economic ruin
was regarded as deeply shameful and
self-evidently
it was entirely his own fault around the
time financial disaster struck
rembrandt painted a self-portrait
burdened with an
honest deeply sorrowful awareness of his
own idiocy and folly
it is evident in his eyes that he knows
he doesn't deserve anyone's sympathy
fittingly given what he had gone through
his culminating masterpiece
painted at the very end of his life
relates to another
more famous character who has behaved in
a clearly appalling way
the picture illustrates a parable from
the new testament known as
the prodigal son the kneeling man has
been prodigal
in the sense of profligate he took his
father's money
ran away and spent it all on wine women
in song
the prodigal son stands in for rembrandt
himself
the waster who has brought ruin and
disgrace upon himself
the son deserves to be hounded and
humiliated
but this is not the reception he gets in
the painting
the elderly father figure greets his son
with great compassion and gentleness
instead of giving his son the stern
condemnation that he deserves
the father provides the love warmth and
forgiveness the son
needs the picture conveys rembrandt's
moving
and very intimate realization about the
true nature of love
it reaches out to the selfish idiot to
the wastrel
to the passion-driven fool love properly
understood
is destined also for the undeserving
perhaps rembrandt's most moving work is
a modest looking print entitled
christ preaching significantly it isn't
set in galilee or jerusalem in the 1st
century a.d
instead the message of kindness is being
preached in a
street of a dutch town in other words
to rembrandt's contemporaries the
message can be boiled down to three
words
i love you and it's being beamed out to
precisely the kinds of people
who in rembrandt's day reviewed with
some justification
as particularly odious they are we can
guess
thieves layabouts drunks pimps
and people who lent money at terrifying
rates of interest
mean employers and con artists if
rembrandt were creating this work today
we might see ranged around the alleyway
the representative
unlovable figures of our times a
politician who incites conflict
the owner of a newspaper that puts
profit above truth
someone who is proud of their vulgarity
a snobbish socialite
an arms trader a feral youth a sexual
deviant
or the kind of person who seems to take
satisfaction and distressing others
it is to them that the message of love
is being directed
rembrandt's key insight is that everyone
needs
love whether they deserve it or not if
we wait to be kind only to those who
deserve kindness
we will be waiting for a very long time
in fact
we'll have turned into monsters
our relationships book calmly guides us
with calm and charm
through the key issues of relationships
to ensure that success in love
need not be a matter of good luck for
more
click the link now